backlash is growing over we're the
world's top bottled water producer gets
its supplies Nestle it collects millions
of gallons a year from Springs in
Southern California an area that's
actually prone to drought and as the
company tries to meet the rising demand
activists are voicing their concern
mariah via al got a rare look at one of
the springs at the heart of the
controversy in the mountains next to San
Bernardino California in the San
Bernardino Mountains outside Los Angeles
this intricate maze of pipes collects
and funnels tens of millions of gallons
of water each year it's the original
source for Nestle's Arrowhead water but
the steep terrain covered in thick brush
is only easily accessible by helicopter
Larry Lawrence who manages this spring
for Nestle waters brought us deep into
the canyon these are naturally flowing
sources we don't pump anything we don't
siphon anything just naturally flows in
the pipe spring water collects in this
tunnel and moves downhill through this
pipeline from the top of the pipeline to
the very bottom is 7.2 miles at the
bottom tanker trucks load and transport
it to a nearby plant where they bottle
the water the water business is booming
bottled water sales are up nearly 9%
over the last year which has set Nestle
looking for new sources to meet customer
demand of their current 40 water sources
around the country eleven are in
California state dealing with long-term
drought concerns every gallon of water
that is taken out of a natural system
for bottled water is a gallon of water
that doesn't flow down a stream that
doesn't support a natural ecosystem
Nestle has faced protests over its water
collection in California both because of
the drought and the fact that this site
is on public land while the company
takes about 30 million gallons each year
they paid just five hundred and
twenty-four dollars to the u.s. Forest
Service for the permit I think it's fair
to say that in this case our public
agencies have dropped the ball the
Forest Service is now reviewing Nestle's
permit for the first time in 30 years
they declined our request for an
interview I don't think there's anybody
quite frankly that outperforms Nelson
Switzer is Nestle Waters chief
sustainability officer some people say
this is the people's water is it fair
that you guys make so much money off of
it Nestle has water rights of course in
this area from a legal standpoint of
course it's fair from a perception
standpoint I understand why people are
asking that question but water belongs
to no one
Switzer says Nestle takes its
responsibility as a water steward very
seriously the sustainability of the
supply is paramount and that if our
activities were to compromise the
sustainability of that supply we would
stop operating I hope people remember
that water itself is a renewable
resource as long as that is managed
really that system will be renewable
forever it may be renewable but as long
as companies like Nestle make a profit
off it the debate over public natural
resources will continue for CBS this
morning midday a vehicle in the San
Bernardino Mountains